by Nathan Lindsay and he's going to tell
us about the presentation field in
relations to TCS and extremely Community
talks so take it away
thanks
so uh thanks for sticking around for the
last talk
um so it's a survey talk so hopefully
this is uh appropriate for the last talk
so we can relax a little bit won't have
to follow too many proofs
so here's the outline so I'm going to
start off by describing a suitcase for
traveling beyond the Boolean Cube and
then um I'm going to argue that you
already have some clothes packed in this
suitcase but you don't know it and then
uh once I do that we're I'm just going
to tell a bunch of short stories about
how representation pops up in places
like extreme accommodatorics Boolean
functions and the places you wouldn't
expect in like a theoretical computer
science
okay so this uh the suitcase that I'm
talking about is uh Association schemes
okay so we're gonna Define these so just
let X N be a set
and I have a bunch of matrices now and
I'm going to insist that they're binary
and I want them to be indexed by the
elements of my set
so as we progress you'll see that these
matrices must have more and more
structure but for now binary matrices
okay so we say that it's an association
scheme if we have a zero is equal to the
identity Matrix
I'm going to if I'm inside a then so is
my transpose okay so if I'm one of these
a matrices and my transpose is also in
there
and then I need the sum of my matrices
to sum up to the all ones Matrix
or sorry the uh yes the all ones Matrix
which we're denoting as uh j n
okay so um this condition three uh you
can think of these AIS as being like
um standard basis vectors so that's a
good way to think of them
okay and so I sum them up I get the all
ones Matrix and then this last condition
here is that it's a strong one and I
want these matrices to commute
okay and these are pijks we call these
things uh structure constants
so uh these are the the structure
constants of the algebra generated by
these uh these AIS
okay
so uh in this talk most of these uh
matrices that we're dealing with are
going to be symmetric okay so the two
will be vacuously satisfied then we call
it a symmetric Association scheme
and these AIS that we we have here we're
going to call these associates hence the
name Association scheme there had to be
a reason okay
so um yeah the span of this uh it's a
fancy name the Bose Messner algebra
don't be scared by it's just uh you know
we're just just the algebra generated by
these AIS
Le so uh well you know what what makes
Association schemes really cool
is the fact that we have this uh nice
Duality so if I if I satisfy all these
axioms of an association scheme
then I also get for free I get a dual
basis and uh this dual basis is in terms
of these uh
technical term is a primitive item
potent but what these things are eigen
projectors okay so they're positive
semi-definite matrices and they project
onto eigenspaces and
I get that e0 has to be the all ones
Matrix uh normalized so automatically if
you know if this is one of my eigen
projectors and I know that my AIS they
have to be regular
so these AIS these associates these are
just regular graphs and they're like
they have a lot of nice uh combinatorial
regularity
okay
for this talk yes yeah but in general
they don't have to be
so
is your Axiom that they just created so
that their product is in the span of the
book
yes yes exactly
okay so um
because property of three is important
so it's a these primitive item codes
or these eigen projectors they give me a
resolution of the identity
and I have this interesting last
condition uh so these uh qijks
these are known as uh cried parameters
and uh you can think of these as being
like dual structure constants
and um this product that we have now is
it's entry-wise so this is the uh the
Freshman Matrix products if you will
yeah so
um
so yeah I mean
it's quite obvious that the the Symmetry
that's happening here so this is this is
a really beautiful Duality property here
and I think a lot of us are comfortable
with abelian groups and uh you know if I
if I just let these AIS be permutation
matrices I'd realize some abelian group
and then I get that these uh these eihs
these are just uh Matrix versions of the
the Dual characters and this entry-wise
uh product that we're doing is like
Point wise product that we get with the
Dual characters
so yeah this is kind of boring if you're
just doing a billion groups so let's
make things interesting so these AIS
let's let them be uh normal calligraphs
of a uh non-abelian group
and so uh by normal calligraphs we mean
that their generating set is a
conjugacity class so each of these AIS
think of them as being the adjacency
Matrix of a normal Kaley grab generated
by conjugacy class I
now
the matrix product here is just a
concrete realization of a convolution
and so we know that if we uh the order
in which I do convolution in a group
algebra doesn't matter so we have
commutativity for free
and uh so
okay for that later but but anyways I it
like it's uh this so that these
structure constants
um they're actually uh counting
something combinatorial but these qijs
we sort of um
we sort of don't know what's going on
here in general uh so algebra is love to
study these crime parameters so clearly
these uh pijks they have to be like
integers positive integers and these Qi
jks though these could be you know these
could be even irrational so uh this is
sort of an open question in algebraic
combinatorics can you actually make
sense of these crime parameters and they
pop up in Quantum computation a lot so
uh with some joint work with uh ansys
Romanus uh we characterize the crime
parameters of this Association scheme
that comes from the symmetric group but
um they're important so um definitely
worthy of a study
and I want to finally note that uh so I
have two bases I have a primal one and a
dual one so anytime you have two bases
you have to ask okay what's the change
of basis Matrix so turns out that uh
this Matrix p is what we call the the
character table of the association
scheme and this is just a transition
this is just the transition Matrix
between these two bases
and you're probably wondering why are
you calling it a character table well
I've sort of hinted that these things
you know there's a natural way that uh
we can embed groups in this uh more
General scheme but
um so this uh even for non-abelian
groups this character table P
um so it's not quite the character table
of the group there's some row and column
normalization but that's essentially
what it is okay
but uh okay so you're probably wondering
now okay so we we have this thing called
an association scheme and the two
examples you've given me I could do you
know I could do this without all this
extra framework so what's the what's the
trick so um
turns out that these Association schemes
uh you can do like there are domains
that are groups and that's when things
become way more interesting and so this
um
this title here uh it's been uh
Association schemes have been called uh
like group Theory without the groups and
so we'll see some examples of what we
what we mean by this and I think this is
uh this quote's attributed to banai and
Ido
who wrote one of the first textbooks on
uh Association schemes sorry I got my
back turned to this side so try to
orient myself over here
okay so I want to argue that we've
already seen some examples of
Association schemes that aren't
necessarily groups so one is the Hamming
scheme
okay so I take
words of an alphabet of size M and I uh
take two words and I look at their
Hamming distance their Hamming distance
is I then in the associate a I I put a 1
in that entry
okay
the Johnson scheme
I think two case sets I look at the
intersection if it's K minus I then I
put a 1 in the AI entry for that pair of
that pair of case sets
okay and these uh Johnson's games think
of these uh and HDX these are just the
levels of the complete complex
good
and so we've also seen the the Q Hamming
scheme so this is also known as the
bilinear form scheme
and uh for for the condition for being
um you know this notion of distance and
uh the Q Hamming scheme I take two
matrices and I look at their difference
and if they're rank uh if they differ by
a rank I Matrix then I put a one and uh
for the ith associate
and finally the Q Johnson scheme which
is The Grassman scheme
so uh again I take 2K dimensional
subspaces I take their intersection if
their intersection has Dimension K minus
I then I put a 1 in the AI column or in
the AI entry
okay
so I think we all know that uh you know
you can work within these uh domains
without knowing anything about group
representation Theory and this is uh
historically this is this was the case
like uh you could completely understand
these things uh using either inclusion
matrices these are things that we would
call huntas so these are kind of just
these matrices where I have
an indexed by objects of size say k
objects of size K J or indexed by
objects of size J and then you look at
uh
you look at the the entries and you have
a if J is a sub object of K then you put
a one there okay
so it we would call these Hunters okay
but uh they didn't call that uh they
didn't call them such things back in the
day and also these things called
orthogonal polynomials that I'm not
going to get into
okay
so there's more structure that we can
put on us on an association scheme and
it makes it more interesting so uh in
particular it's this uh this this idea
of being metric okay so I haven't really
talked about the ordering of these
associates but uh you know you could
have ordered them arbitrarily but for
being metric this means that I have an
ordering of the associates such that uh
the first associate generates the rest
in particular if I look at the deeth
associate I can write that as a
polynomial
of the first associate
okay so think of this like
think of A1 as being like the hypercube
if I wanted to get something at distance
D in the hypercube I'd take a walk of
length D and then uh I'll have some
other walks that aren't short as paths
and so I have to subtract off by some
lower degree polynomial to get rid of
those but the hypercube uh satisfies
this so if we look at the Hamming Cube
and make a A1 be the hypercube
then we've shown that it's metric
so uh on the Dual side we say that an
association scheme is cometric if I can
order these eigen projectors now in a
similar fashion so E1 through em such
that there's a degree so that I can
write the dth projector
as a polynomial of degree d
we're here my multiplication is again
the The Freshman multiplication
okay and so I argue that you know this
is all this is all old news to us this
is just uh
these are the Fourier levels on the
hypercube okay
so I can write a period degree function
as a polynomial of degree uh D in the
dictators no sweat
okay and so when uh the associations
gave people say commetric you know we're
just thinking of like Fourier levels and
so we have this nice way of ordering the
levels
um where we start with things of low
complexity and then things that are
higher degree have high complexity
okay so this uh hypercube
this Hamming scheme where we have a
two-letter alphabet this is a metric and
a commetric Association scheme
okay
so uh here we are on uh Earth over here
and I think part of this program is uh
to find um
earth-like planets and other places of
math so um I argue that these metric and
cometric Association schemes these are
going to be the closest planets to uh
being Earth-like and uh
many of the these Association schemes
that we've already seen are in fact
metric and cometric so maybe this is the
um
this could be I don't know the Johnson
scheme that's the bilinear form scheme
That's The Grassman scheme but there's
these other planets out here that uh
exist that uh I haven't really seen uh
anybody take a peek at in the TCS
literature and they come from things in
finite geometry and um so I won't get
into it but uh there's lots of other
Association schemes that are metric and
cometric
and uh maybe this is the right
abstraction for uh talking about global
hypercontractivity and uh
maybe these uh graphs like the short
code Johnson and The Grassman graph so
they have their analogs of these for
other associations games and maybe these
also have this property where like
there's only a handful of bad small set
expanders
so I'll just throw that out there
might not be the case but it would be
very strange if uh
something were true for these uh
suspects but not the whole family of
distance regular graphs
so and it's also a pretty rare property
so it's a
I think that uh most people think that
there's finitely many uh of these metric
and cometric Association schemes of
unbounded diameter so there's lots of
sporadic little sporadic examples that
you can find but uh there seems to be
like maybe there's only finitely many of
these earth-like planets so
but there's lots of other uh planets uh
out there in particular a lot of them
come from the symmetra group
so um
yeah so so that's what we'll spend the
rest of the talk
um discussing so we'll see some examples
in the symmetric group and we'll also
see some examples in the uh perfect
matching schemes
and so I think Ryan called the
simplistic group the weird Uncle of the
Lee family
and so what's what's let's call this the
the weird Uncle of the symmetric group
uh family okay so this is uh and in fact
this group here is it actually it
actually is quite similar to the
symplecta group in many ways but
I won't get into that
all right
cool
so the symmetric group scheme
so first we need to discuss what our
conjunct what the associates and the uh
item potents are
right so these are uh indexed by half
eaten chocolate bars
okay so here's the the chocolate bar
that we associate to the integer uh
partition 5331
okay and so the associate corresponding
to this integer partition
it's just uh this is again these are the
Kaley graphs generated by the conjugacy
class corresponding to Lambda
they these e lambdas these are
projectors onto the uh
isotypic components of the of the
regular representation of the symmetric
group so if you don't know what that is
that's fine this just uh it's this
Vector space here where these s lambdas
are the spec modules
and there's a nice uh tidy way of
looking at the dimension of these uh
spec modules and they're these things
that are in terms of a standard young
Tebow okay so what's a standard young
Tableau well here's an example of one
okay so for this shape here I
put the numbers 1 through 12 in the
chocolate bar and I insist that my rows
are strictly increasing and going down
columns I'm also strictly increasing
okay so there's a lot of ways you can do
that and so the dimensions of these
eigenspaces are really big and this is
actually useful in practice uh when
you're doing things in extreme
accommodate works
I won't get into that but it's nice that
they're big for some applications
okay and so this is the picture that I
want us to be thinking about when we're
doing
um
when we're thinking about functions on
the symmetric group so in the hypercube
we had this nice decomposition into
Fourier levels and we have the same
thing for the symmetric group so the way
that we just talk about the levels here
is that I look at the number of cells
below the first row
so I round up all of these v lambdas
such that V Lambda has K cells under the
first row
K or fewer and that's the degree K
functions
okay and over here uh so we had you know
the parity function for the hypercube so
we don't have the parity function but we
have the sine function and it's
essentially the you know it's the
analogous thing for the symmetric group
so so there's this nice uh you know this
nice parallel to what we're used to in
the hypercube
all right
so here's an honest question so if
you're looking at this with fresh eyes
everything is not in the top row of the
like the degree was the number of
elements in that they're not in the top
row right exactly exactly
yeah so now this question when you see
these things for the first time it's
like okay uh well let's let's start with
the basics like what what can I say
about the Boolean degree T functions
okay so the first thing you might think
of is like okay maybe one of these uh TM
roots or these uh these Hunter type
families so these are the ones where uh
I pick T distinct coordinates for the
left-hand side T distinct coordinates
for the right hand side and I insist
that every family every member in my
family maps ik to JK
okay so it's characteristic function as
a polynomial so here our indeterminants
are no longer uh just uh single
variables but pairs of variables so we
have Matrix and determinants
and it's just this you know it's it's
what you'd expect so I plop in a
permutation Matrix and if that when I
plop in the permutation Matrix if that's
a one then that indicates that I'm in
the T number it
okay so I'm putting this in bold but
you know you might think uh this is a
completely obvious right
I have I mean you you just told me these
are the polynomials that indicate my
family of course they're going to be
Fourier degree T functions
and so I would say it actually requires
proof now so we're not in Kansas anymore
okay so uh the hypercube yeah I
completely agree with you but when
you're when you're doing Fourier
analysis over other spaces we have to uh
we have to do representation Theory now
to prove this fact that the power that
the Fourier degree equals the polynomial
degree and it's not hard I mean if
you've taken a first course in it we
have things like uh frobenius
reciprocity and induction those are the
tools that you need to prove such things
but uh it still requires proof and so
and uh it seems like a trivial effect
but this is sort of what drives a lot of
um results in the extreme
accommodatorics uh of the T intersecting
variety which we'll talk about here
momentarily but this is uh you know it
seems trivial but it's actually you know
this is a this is what I think is a deep
effect
uh it's a polynomial degree here is just
I take a function it's the smallest uh t
such that I can write it as a
as a linear combination of those exactly
uh and then the Fourier degree is is uh
is the smallest case such that yeah
we just said yeah but uh
okay
Okay so
as you say it's not like just trivial
from some kind just fine like because of
the like just basically they're just
finding a life invariant
like just basically saying that
they're both intervariants under the
same set of
things
so that's fine if you say no I'm just
I'm not well I think what you're saying
is uh needs to be made more rigorous and
that's kind of what representation does
for you but I
if you uh if you can find an easier way
to do it without representation period
let me know I just meant when you
conjugate those uh like young tableau
uh then basically I mean the I'm just
saying like you there's no easy way to
see this just in terms of uh
sort of the set of operations that that
essentially preserve the space of
monomials that also preserve the space
yeah but you still need to know like
what space those monomials span and so
um and this was done Years Ago by uh
young but it's and so I need to know how
conjugation acts on Young on the young
tableaus so okay
we'll talk about it afterwards
okay so
um it's all right
so we've talked about hunters and so now
uh let's talk more about
um intersecting families okay so what's
the connection here between uh these uh
T umbrits and intersecting families well
um okay so first let's
describe what a two intersecting what it
means to be T intersecting for
permutations okay so I argue for for
sets it's quite obvious but maybe for
permutations it's not so much but a
family permutations is going to be
intersecting if uh any two members uh
degree uh agree on T symbols that means
that uh they agree on where T symbols
are mapped
so another way you can phrase this is
that there are independent sets of this
graph GT and where these uh Associates
are ranging over
Lambda such that Lambda has less than T
ones
okay so this is a regular graph
and the independent sets of this graph
or the T intersecting families and this
is just by definition okay so this graph
it lives in an association scheme so
that's going to be important
but that's an equivalent way of defining
T intersecting
so now these T these T inverts these are
pretty big intersecting families okay
they have size n minus t factorial
okay because I fixed T coordinates and
then I let the rest vary that can be
whatever whatever you want
but is this the best that we can do okay
so this we got we have a a good lower
bound on these two intersecting families
uh is this that is this upper is this
actually an upper bound as well
so deza and Frankel uh two famous uh
extreme will come in a tourists they
seem to think so and this was a
conjecture from back in the 70s and uh
this conjecture has been very important
in extreme accommodatorics it's like
this is so this the first paper by uh
Ellis Friedman papill was uh I think one
of the first it was like one the the
first time that uh we we went beyond the
cube in a non-trivial way I think uh in
the extreme accommodate works and it's
really it's spawned a lot of creativity
there's been a a saga of really
impressive work that's followed it uh
where more ingenious ways of uh proving
this theorem have been discovered and uh
as we get further to the right on the
list the this in this function here
becomes uh closer to the truth
okay still not solved in its entirety uh
but uh it's we have very good bounds on
what uh and not can be
but it's it's a very important theorem
and uh I'm gonna talk uh a bit about the
first proof which uses uh the Hoffman
bound so I think we've seen the Hoffman
bound maybe already uh in this in this
uh Workshop but uh remind us so
it's a it's a bound on the independence
number of a graph Alpha G based on the
largest and least eigenvalues
so I can find uh so a is going to be any
weighted adjacency Matrix of G
and uh we can bound the size of the
independence number uh in terms of the
the largest and least eigenvalues okay
and so if equality holds then we get a
stronger condition and namely that the
the characteristic vectors at these
maximum independent sets they all have
to lie in the uh direct sum of the
greatest and least eigenspaces so this
gives us additional structure and this
is going to be uh crucial for this uh
but when we sketch the proof of this uh
result by Ellis fried good and papel
okay but I want to note before we sketch
this proof that the best bounds are on
this for this problem are known by a
hyper-contractivity results on the
symmetra group and this is uh due to
Nathan Keller gnome lift shits uh door
menzer and uh odd scheinfeld
okay and so hopefully we'll hear more
about this uh this result uh down here
at the bottom uh as the workshop
progresses so it's a
it's very nice
okay but let's talk about uh let's go
over a sketch of the uh Ellis Friedman
papel result okay so recall that we had
this graph okay this graph is like
encoding our problem of finding a
maximum T intersecting family I want to
know what I want to characterize the
maximum independent sets of this graph
okay so as you know this is a hopeless
question in general but this is a very
structured graph and so we have a we
have a chance of doing something
and so we want to find a weighted
adjacency Matrix a of GT we're going to
normalize this thing so that the maximum
eigenvalue is one
all right and then we want to find uh we
want equality to hold in the Hoffman
bound
and so we want uh we want this to be
true we want this quality to be true
okay so we fixed uh we fixed everything
else we just solve for the minimum
eigenvalue okay call that call that Zeta
okay
so what's crucial here is that if
equality does hold then by this
condition the second condition of
Hoffman's bound then we know that these
maximum independent sets they have to
they have to lie in the span of the
least and largest eigen spaces
but we know we are we already have an
idea of what these should be this should
be the uh the T umber it's that we just
talked about and remember we said that
the T number it's these were the uh they
spanned the Fourier levels from zero to
T
so we already had so it's not we're not
just shooting in the dark here uh trying
to find a weighted adjacency Matrix
right if I tell you to find a way to
adjacency Matrix that's like more than
enough rope to hang yourself with right
so we need to know more if we're going
to ever expect to find an a that meets
this with equality
and so
at least we know that uh what the
eigenvalue should be for the level zero
through t okay
it turns out that this is this is
actually going to be enough
and so rather than arbitrarily placing
weights on the graph we're gonna we're
gonna wait now our Associates that
compose
GT
and so because these things come from an
association scheme when we find these
weights when we put weights on the
associates this has a completely
predictable property on the eigenvalues
okay so and it just uh
they're simultaneously diagonalizable
and so this means that uh
we can when we place these weights we
can actually analyze what the spectrum
of this this weighted graph is going to
be
and so
we solve a linear system for X but this
isn't just any old linear system you
have to be very careful about which one
of your system you choose in order to uh
find these weights X Lambda and this is
where it's like knowing a thing or two
about representation theory of the
symmetric group is extremely helpful
and so this is uh in particular like
asymptotic properties about uh about the
representation theory of the symmetric
group The buzzword of math is
representation stability and so these
properties uh it's useful to know them
and then argue that after you solve this
linear system you get the x's and then
as n is when n is sufficiently large
then Zeta is in fact the least
eigenvalue
okay and so that's that's the gist of
the proof and I wanted to go over this
proof because it's um
there's actually a lot of proofs in
extreme accommodatorics of T
intersecting results that that proceed
in this manner
okay so it's like it's so if you get the
gist of this proof then you get the gist
of a lot of these T intersecting results
and another way of looking at this um is
that this this Hoffman bound is actually
an upper bound on um the lovage Theta
number
okay and then uh so the lovage Theta
number is uh the Lobos Theta number is a
uh it's a relaxation of the um it's a
semi-definite relaxation of the the
independence number of a graph and uh
sandwiched in between is uh the the
Shannon capacity of a graph so when you
have equality holding in the Hoffman
bound you're actually showing something
stronger you're showing uh that you
you've characterized the Shannon
capacity of the graph as well and this
is a very hard question in general in
fact we don't even know if it's
decidable and so uh to these spectral
proofs I want to kind of I want to argue
that uh okay maybe they're outclassed in
some respects by the analytical methods
that uh we know now but you know it
technically it gives stronger results
all right so maybe that's all I want to
say about the T intersecting families
so I want to consider a new problem now
where um the Hoffman bound fails
spectacularly okay
so
we're going to Define this graph
we're still in the symmetric group
Association scheme
and these this is the sum of the
associates that are these uh these hook
shape partitions okay
so I have a again a regular graph that's
some of these uh these hook Associates
and I argue that this is uh this is
actually the one skeleton of a very
important polytope in combinatorial
optimization namely this uh thing called
the burkhoff polytope or if equivalently
the perfect matching polytop of k n n
okay and so uh you know the way to see
that is that two vertices are adjacent
in the perfect matching polytope of k n
n or any graph for that matter if when I
take
so when I take their difference I get a
single cycle okay
so that so that condition defines the
edges of uh the burkoff polytope
so this actually came up quite naturally
in a pain by Kane Lovett and uh Rao in
17 when they were looking at a coding
Theory question where they wanted to
bound the size of an alphabet in these
uh class of codes called maximally
recoverable so
I won't explain how they reduced it to
this problem it's it's quite clever but
uh their problem it amounted to
determining what what you know what's
the independence number of this graph
yeah
so if you plug in so if you compute the
eigenvalues of this graph it's uh it can
be done it's it's no picnic but uh even
if you do it then uh naively Hoffman
only gives you n minus one factorial
and this seems far from the truth
because these one skeletons of uh zero
and polytopes they shouldn't have
independent sets so they're that big so
this seems like a lie
and so what KLR did and uh 2017 was give
a structure versus pseudor Randomness
argument okay
and uh it gives a
substantially better bound and that's
what they needed for their result
and so the way it works the way that the
pseudorandom argument went is as follows
so I I take a set of the symmetric group
and if that's not pseudorandom or Global
so I'm being a little bit big here but
uh what this means essentially is that
many members agree on the same uh on
some simple set
okay and when you have many members
agreeing on some symbol set that means
that you can get a density bump so you
just restrict to those families to those
members that agree on that tea set and
then recurse okay easy enough
that's not the case then they use
Fourier analysis on the symmetric group
to show that these two there must be two
permutations that differ by an End Cycle
okay and uh the way that they did that
was uh using this uh this nice fact from
representation theory that uh if you've
been attending the representation Theory
reading group you've seen this it's the
fact that this uh this associate here so
this uh this guy up here the single
cycle it has a very sparse
Fourier support
so I can write it in the e-basis as a
you know just in uh item potency not uh
you know the number of partitions many
you know there's many many uh lambdas
but it's only supported on the hooks
this is quite remarkable and so this
simplified their analysis greatly to
where they could show that uh if I so if
I have some family that's not that's
pseudo-random then I have to have some
support on the End Cycle
and if I have support on the End Cycle
then I'm not independent and so that's
uh that's essentially the proof
and uh so I think Fernando's in the
audience uh so uh with his co-author uh
Greg liano they were able to improve um
they were able to improve KLR by
considering more than just the End Cycle
so this argument is just the End Cycle
right but I have these other Cycles
if you consider more of these other
Cycles then you get better bounds
and so they conjecture that
um the the proper bound should be uh
2N rather than 1.97 and uh I believe
them
okay so open questions here that have
been uh kind of uh
discussed around the the workshop so
what what about The Clique numbers of
these graphs so um
if you can I argue this is another
interesting question and if you could uh
solve this for like the non-bipartite
analog which I won't get into uh you can
you can look at the matching polytope of
k2n
so then you can look at uh it's one
skeleton and if you can tell me what The
Clique number of that graph is and there
would be some applications to structural
graph theory that would be nice but it
seems like a hard question
okay so moving on to the the perfect
matching scheme
so this is the weird uncle that we're
going to talk about now that nobody
talks about but uh but me the the weird
uncle was the subject of my uh
dissertation so I know a lot about him
so um
so first off there's uh so if I take the
odd numbers less than 2N and I multiply
them all together this is like the odd
double factorial and that's how many
perfect matchings there are because uh
we can realize the uh perfect matchings
as a quotient of the symmetric group so
they're cosets we're modding out by uh
this uh thing that's related to the
Simplex if you're it's called the
hyperoctahedral group
okay so we have an analogous relation
for our Associates of this Association
scheme now so it's more combinatorial so
I you know if you take the union of two
perfect matchings I get a disjoint Union
of even Cycles divide each of those
cycle links by two I get an integer
partition of N and um so if that's your
isomorphism type when a union two
perfect matchings together I put a one
there
okay and so these uh projectors these
are uh similar to the symmetra group but
now
we're just projecting onto the spec
module where this two Lambda means that
I'm doubling each part of a Lambda
okay so I won't get into it but there's
a there's a parallel story to these uh T
intersecting results for the perfect
matching scheme and it's uh it's a it's
a similar so it's a similar Journey that
you take with uh
that was free good and Propel but you
need to sort of know more algebra and
you have to do things from scratch
because there's less things that you can
take off the shelf when you're studying
perfect matchings and so some of these
you have to develop yourself and so
that's that's basically uh the gist of
it
but uh what I really want to talk about
is this um
it's this thing called the matchings
connectivity Matrix which uh this was
really unexpected by the way like um
this uh I was reading some papers by
crotch um
uh saigen and nederloff a while ago
where they were looking at parameterized
algorithms for counting hamiltonian
Cycles module two
sounds a little silly you know perfect
matchings if I want to count perfect
matchings module two I just compute a
determinant so but when you do uh when
you do hamiltonian Cycles it's still a
hard problem and so uh they um it's
quite interesting actually so they were
looking at parameterized algorithms you
know things parameterized by like tree
with path with you name it with and um
and so they were
and then this this Matrix came up and so
it was used as sort of a in a data
structure that they had and uh what just
for nederlock found was that this Matrix
here which is just the N associate of
the perfect matching scheme it had like
incredibly low rank over gf2
and uh when you have incredibly low rank
then you can represent this Matrix uh
using far fewer than two n minus one
factorial double factorial um
vectors so it's uh and this led to some
some nice speed ups and uh so counting
hamiltonian Cycles modulo two and even
uh determining hamiltonicity in some of
these uh graph classes
so uh remember this is so the uh the the
less weird uh version of an uh in the
symmetra group
this had sparse Fourier support so we
said that it was supported on the hooks
and this is what like led to that nice
result by KLR
and so uh the question is what so maybe
a similar phenomenon happens here
for the matching connectivity Matrix
and so it turns out that it does so this
is what uh
kurtica Pian I think uh and uh and just
for never love and myself showed
um
so here it's not a sum over the hooks
but it's over a sum over these things
that don't have this chocolate bar as a
as a sub shape
so if this were hooks then it would just
be the the two by two uh chocolate bar
but this is the three by two chocolate
bar
and so remember that this F2 Lambda
we're counting standard young Tableau of
shape to Lambda and so these are so the
rank of this thing is is quite sparse
compared this to 2N minus one double
factorial it's quite small
and uh and this notation here this is a
meaning we're like sweeping polynomials
even under the rug and uh but for
parameterized complexity for uh
or hard results they're fine with that
so yeah we don't care about polynomials
just uh just tell me the exponent
okay and so this result uh this I won't
get into the details here there's not
much representation theory if any uh in
uh how we
conclude this it's a it's a difficult
reduction but once you have this bound
on the rank you can show that a lot of
these known parameterized algorithms
for parameter sdp algorithms for
counting hamiltonian Cycles are optimal
assuming the strong exponential time
hypothesis so
so
this is uh this is a place where
representation Theory uh I mean it sort
of naturally comes at you you have this
very symmetric Matrix and you want to
know its Rank and so this is a very
doable thing so and in general like uh
anytime you're dealing with matrices
that are invariant under some group
action you should be using
representation Theory so this is uh all
the examples that we've seen so far fall
into this category so that's uh you know
if you pick up anything from this talk
just know that that's a good rule of
thumb for using representation Theory
okay and so I could not for the life of
me figure out what the rank of this
Matrix was for primes other than two so
that was already done by gesture but uh
if you could do this then you could get
uh results uh Seth hardness results for
counting hamiltonian Cycles uh module of
peace
so that would be uh be quite interesting
so uh and you know the representation
Theory way of attacking this would be
like to look at modular representation
Theory
and that's much harder that's much
harder than what we've been discussing
here so we've been in the in the
characteristic zero case and so um
it's quite difficult
all right so what do we got here we've
got about five minutes left if I'm
counting correctly
um
so I want to conclude with some new work
that I've been doing with Yuval filmus
and the co-authors and uh this is um
we'll call it new beginnings of Boolean
functions okay so I I I definitely
dodged a question that we asked many
many slides ago and that was um can we
classify the Boolean degree K or
whatever functions
so I gave you one example of some but I
certainly certainly didn't classify them
and this turns out to be a very
difficult Pro
okay so even for D equals two this seems
like a hard problem
and even if we go to The Grassman scheme
we still don't know yet what the answer
is for D equals one and this is Joint
work or this I'm not part of this paper
this is filmus and eringer
um this was done somewhat recently
so for D equals one uh it's kind of what
you'd expect it's like these disjoint
unions of dictators
no surprises there but even you know for
D equals two we have no idea
and so this um you know the natural
question here at this point is like okay
well if we can't
classify things completely then can we
do this indirectly and so the way we do
this in the analysis of Boolean
functions is via complexity measures and
so then the natural question is these
complexity measures on the Boolean Cube
do they uh do they go beyond uh to the
symmetric group and even further and
this was a joint work with uh several
co-authors
um so all of these uh all these
complexity measures uh appropriately
defined which I want to find them but
they can be defined appropriately and uh
and they do that they do generalize
quite nicely so they're all polynomially
related and so um the place where
representation Theory rears its head up
the most would be uh probably in this
proof of the uh of sensitivity
so we use uh representation theory in a
very clever way there to show an analog
of the sensitivity conjecture for uh the
symmetric group but I won't get into
that into the details at least and uh I
want to conclude with um
some recent work with Yuval filmus on
harmonic polynomials on the symmetric
group
okay so I think maybe by now we know
that um
okay even like classifying Boolean
degree D functions
on these other domains these other
earth-like planets
um it seems hard I won't say impossible
but it's hard
um so uh let's even let's go for an even
easier question so uh on the hypercube
this is like chapter one of O'Donnell's
book you know everything uh admits a
unique multi-linear representation so is
this is this true when we travel beyond
the cube it's not true okay so uh take
the the Johnson scheme
so I argue that if I plop in a case set
here that's always going to be zero
trivial reasons
even more trivial for the symmetric
group I can't have two uh I can't have
two edges uh adjacent to the same vertex
and this is like the uh you know the
constraints and the uh bipartite uh
matching polytope right so this always
has to be true and put the one over
there then it's the same constraints
that you've seen before in combinatorial
optimization
so there's lots of different ways you
can write the zero function and this is
sort of you know the pump the brakes uh
we should we should figure this out
before we try to go seriously uh beyond
the cube and so um
for the Johnson scheme Duncan gave a
found a way around this by giving a
unique harmonic multilinear
representation for functions on the
slice so what does this mean okay so I
take all the so I have a function and I
take all the ways that I can write this
function as a polynomial the only one of
those ways is going to be annihilated by
a particular
differential operator that Dunkel
defines and I won't get into the details
of this but there's a there's a
canonical way of writing things on the
slice as a harmonic multi-linear
polynomial harmonic here just means that
it's annihilated by some differential
operator that we Define
so the question is okay well can we we
did this for the symmetric group
so can we generalize um dunkle's result
of the symmetra group
and uh yeah so we have about a minute
left and so I've defined uh yeah so all
I'm going to say is yes
we can and uh so if you want to you can
check out this uh somewhat new result
the devil and I showed where um we were
able to do this on the symmetra group
but also more generally on uh perfect
matchings and so here you can sort of
think of these symmetric group and
perfect matchings of k2n as being sort
of the
so very very similar they're both
perfect so SN this is just perfect
matchings of k n okay
so uh there's a a cool way of like
proving results in algebraic
combinatorics for SN and perfect
matchings of k2n simultaneously so you
don't have to like have two separate
proofs necessarily and these things are
called uh Jack polynomials in it I won't
get into the details there but it's uh
there's some really cool algebraic
combinatorics that pops up when you
start answering these sorts of questions
about uh the questions that we care
about uh moving to other earth-like
planets and so it has connections to
other areas of math okay and so it's um
I think there's opportunity for
cross-pollination here so I think I'll
leave it at that but uh thanks for your
time
[Applause]
questions
so here do you have like instead of SN
if you have positive groups of like type
B or type c
so
we haven't thought about that but that's
a
that's a good I would imagine that uh
what's that probably works it probably
works yeah yeah yeah so uh
yeah I guess
yeah so for for B and I I definitely see
how it would work but maybe for DM
's even weirder uncle right
example that nobody writes
dude to do stuff
all the other like public matching skin
and stuff but they're just taking
portions of their son and somehow
lifting it to us and the problem so
um
yeah it could be that these uh
hyper contractivity and things like that
you can realize this on the symmetric
group around the perfect matching scheme
by by doing these questions I haven't
worked out the details uh what I'm
really interested in for these 200
second results is like getting exact uh
I know that might be a unpopular year
but like uh getting like what the you
know uh getting exact bounce so like for
all n greater than 2T
yeah like we have for sets so like this
is some uh you know if you've seen some
of these uh
so perfect we gave we uh you know we
punted into Infinity to say that
everything works out uh with these
minimum eigenvalues but uh if you look
at the a similar proof for the Johnson
scheme they don't in fact they they go
for it on Fourth and goal and they and
they make it so they do they do things
exactly and uh so that I'm thinking uh
maybe some of this uh uh stuff that Hugo
and I have been doing might have uh a
chance of solving it exactly that's very
wishful thinking but uh I haven't given
up yet
again
[Applause]